Multiplique 3x más 2
por 5x menos7 y aquí lo que tenemos son dos binomios,
los binomios tienen 2 términos que se están sumando,
y te voy a enseñar a desarrollar esta multiplicación de dos formas distintas,
una muy mecánica, a mí la verdad no me gusta hacer las cosas mecánicamente
porque ¿Cuál es el problema de hacerlo de esta forma? Que cuando tengas
35 años se te va a olvidar la palabra mágica que hacía que las cosas funcionaran y
entonces no vas a poder hacer la multiplicación de estos dos binomios.
Sin embargo si entiendes por qué la multiplicación de dos binomios es lo que es,
ahí si te vas a acordar hasta que tengas 100 años pero, vamos a empezar por la forma mecánica.
Y después vamos a ver porqué funciona la forma mecánica.
Porque tal vez te puedes encontrar con esta
nemotecnia en el salón de clases entonces, es importante conocerla ¿Ok? La nemotecnia, la palabra mágica es PAAU.
¿Ok? Lo estoy haciendo chistoso apropósito para que te acuerdes que son dos A y no nada más una. Entonces tenemos aquí a PAAU,
que es PAAU ¿Ok? Son dos A ¡Muy importante! Eso de que sean dos A.
La P es de los primeros
términos, alguna de las A, la que tú quieras, es la A de los términos de afuera, afuera
la otra A es la de los términos de adentro, adentro
y la U es la de los últimos términos, últimos.
Los primeros términos son el primer término de cada paréntesis.
¿Ok? Y entonces usando a PAAU tenemos que tomar los primeros
términos de cada paréntesis y entonces, tenemos al primer término de este paréntesis
por el primer término de este paréntesis,
y entonces nos queda 3x por 5x,
después le queremos sumar los términos de afuera, y pues los términos de afuera son
estos dos términos, con todo y su símbolo de menos, aunque entonces tenemos por aquí 3x por -7
y ahora nos toca los términos de adentro y los términos de adentro son
estos 2 o sea que nos queda 2 por 5x
y finalmente nos faltan los últimos
términos ¿Ok? Este es el último término de este paréntesis
y este es el último término de este otro paréntesis.
Entonces nos quedan 2 por -7 y listo.
Este es el desarrollo de esta multiplicación, de estos dos binomios y en el fondo lo que
PAAU hace es verificar que multiplique cada uno de estos términos
por todos los términos del otro paréntesis.
¿Ok? Tenemos aquí a 3x por 5x
aquí está, y tenemos aquí a
3x por -7 está aquí, y lo mismo para el 2 tenemos a 2 por 5x aquí está
y 2 por -7 que está por aquí y eso se debe a la propiedad distributiva.
Seguramente te acuerdas de ella, lo que nos dice la propiedad distributiva
es que si tenemos aquí "a" por "b" más "c"
esto de aquí es igual a "a" por "b", "a" por "b" más "a" por "c"
pero bueno antes de ver este otro método que usa la propiedad
distributiva para ver cuánto vale esta multiplicación de dos binomios,
pues vamos a terminar con este método ¿No? Este si ya es el
desarrollo de esta multiplicación
pero, todavía se puede simplificar ¿Ok?Aquí tenemos 3x por 5x y esto es igual a
3 por 5
15 y aquí tenemos "x" elevado a la potencia 1 y otra "x" elevada a la potencia 1.
Entonces si multiplicamos estas dos cantidades nos queda
"x" elevado a la 1 más 1, o sea elevado al
cuadrado. Por aquí lo que tenemos es 3x por -7 entonces 3 por 7 es -21,
entonces nos queda -21
y nos falta multiplicar por la "x" así es que aquí va una "x".
Ahora de aquí 2 por 5 es 10
y tenemos una "x" y finalmente 2 por -7 es -14
-14, ahora aquí hay otros 2 términos que se pueden simplificar un poco más, que tenemos aquí
una sola "x" y aquí también tenemos una sola "x"
entonces podemos agrupar
estos 2 términos y hacer algo así como la propiedad
distributiva inversa, por que aquí tenemos una "x" que está multiplicando a -21 y a 10 también
entonces, eso es igual a "x" por -21 más
10 y -21 más 10 es -11 entonces, de estos dos términos tenemos -11 por "x"
este término lo bajamos aquí -14
y este término también lo bajamos nos queda 15x cuadrada ¿Ok?
Este es el resultado de hacer esta multiplicación de binomios y recuerda está
nemotecnia. Lo único que hace es hacer que multipliques
cada uno de los términos de éste paréntesis con
cada uno de los términos del otro paréntesis ¿Ok?
Muy bien y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es el segundo método,
que lo que hace es utilizar la propiedad
distributiva dos veces ¿Ok? Tenemos por aquí 3x más 2 por 5x menos 7.
Entonces vamos a aplicar la propiedad distributiva dos veces, tenemos por aquí a
5x menos 7 por 3x más 2.
¿Ok? Entonces pensamos en este paréntesis como una sola cosa,
ahora recuerda que podemos cambiar estos 2 del lugar porque se están multiplicando,
y entonces vamos a multiplicar todo este paréntesis por
3x como si este paréntesis fuera la "a" en la fórmula de la propiedad distributiva
y a eso le vamos a sumar
todo este paréntesis por 2 ¿Ok? Entonces
haciendo la propiedad distributiva nos queda 3x
3x por nuestro paréntesis que es
5x menos 7 más 2 por nuestro
paréntesis 2 por 5x menos 7
y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es volver a aplicar la propiedad
distributiva pero, con cada uno de estos paréntesis.
Entonces nos va a quedar 3x por 5x y luego 3x por menos7
y en este paréntesis nos va a quedar 2 por
5x más 2 por menos7 y escogí el color de estas flechas
completamente a propósito aquí 3x por 5x es
exactamente este término, aquí 3x por -7 también es
exactamente este término y de
este lado 2 por 5x lo tenemos por acá y 2 por -7 también lo tenemos por acá.
Así es que ya sabes tienes que aplicar la propiedad distributiva 2 veces
y entonces en lugar de aprenderte una palabra como PAAU
puedes simplemente recordar
la propiedad distributiva y listo.